Genau,
dann kann man noch zum letzten
Teil, das sind die Vorloops,
und
Vorloops ist
auch wieder ein sehr
starkes
Dual beim Programmieren,
und damit
kann man eben
zum Beispiel durch Listen iterieren,
das schaut dann so aus,
also wenn man sich das dann
vorstellt im Pseudocode, also einfach
in normaler Sprache,
für jedes Element
in meiner Sequence
oder in meiner Liste
führe ich eine Art und Weise aus.
Das sieht man, das ist auch wieder ein Block,
das schaut dann so aus,
vor Item,
praktisch Item in diesem Fall
ist eine neue Variable-Namen,
den ich hier definiere,
in List of Items,
also diese List of Items habe ich
schon davor definiert,
und dann
prönt ich das einfach hier aus.
Ich kann natürlich in diesem Block
auf dieses Item hier zugreifen,
ich kann natürlich auch auf diese Liste direkt zugreifen,
aber
diese Variable nennt man auch Laufvariable,
weil die mit der
Schleife mitläuft, praktisch die verändert sich
mit jeder Iteration,
bis praktisch alle Elemente
in dieser Liste durchgegangen worden sind,
und die könnt ihr eben einen beliebigen Namen geben,
da wird auch wieder
Variable namens
Regeln beachten,
und innerhalb dieser Schleife
wird das eben so wiederholt,
bis diese Liste abgearbeitet wurde.
Das heißt, wenn wir hier
1, 2, 3 haben,
dann wird diese Liste, also wird
dieser Sprint-Statement hier
dreimal ausgeführt, für jedes Element einzeln.
Das schaut dann eben so zum Beispiel aus,
hier in diesem Fall zum Beispiel
habe ich eine Liste
Lectures definiert,
die praktisch da Mathe,
Englisch, Computer Science
drin,
und dann iteriere ich darüber,
das heißt, ich mache hier meine
Für neue Variable,
also in diesem Fall Lecture,
wie ihr seht, fehlt das S, also
das macht man normalerweise so,
dass man die Liste
im Mehrzahl definiert,
und die Laufvariable
singular
in Lectures
und dann Print, dann hier mit
einem Format-String, I Love Lecture,
das heißt, hier bekommen wir dann
die Ausgabe Math,
Englisch, Computer Science, also
I Love Math, I Love Englisch,
I Love Computer Science.
Genau, also
das ist die Definition
der Initialisierung der Liste,
also unsere
Vorschleife,
und das ist dann der innere Block,
der dann immer in der Vorschleife ausgeführt wird.
Das kann man sich dann so vorstellen.
Genau, es gibt dann
natürlich
man kann natürlich auch
zum Beispiel über jedes
einzelne Zeichen
in einem String drüber iterieren.
Das heißt,
kann ich mal kurz herzeigen.
Vor
Zeit
den
genannten
Warte.
Okay.
Ich kann da
auch das String hier direkt
definieren,
wenn ich das so möchte.
Ich kann ja auch zum Beispiel hier
eine Liste direkt definieren.
Das geht auch.
Also die muss nicht davor definiert werden,
die kann auch hier so definiert werden.
Hallo,
dann hier wichtig,
auch beim IF Statement
ist dieser Doppelpunkt
und
dann kann ich machen
Print
Ciao.
Und dann macht er mir da
das Einzelnen.
Ich kann da zum Beispiel dann
Einzeln sagen, okay,
das soll dann mal
nünftig multipliziert werden.
Also
solche Sachen sind auch möglich.
Gibt es dazu Fragen?
Okay.
Was für Werte müsste ich hier reinschreiben,
wenn ich von 1 bis 10 zählen möchte
in dieser Range?
Das erste Fragezeichen.
1 und 11,
genau, ja.
Weil hier praktisch
mit 1 starten
und 11 ist dann exklusiv,
das heißt
11 wird nicht mehr
in dieser Zahlsequenz vorkommen.
Und praktisch
wie ihr seht, kann man da nämlich auch
diese Zahlsequenzen, also diese Range
verwenden, um dann sehr schnell
über Nummern zu iterieren.
Wenn ihr zum Beispiel
hier eine Liste habt
und ihr wollt aber auch wissen
welches Element der Liste ich gerade,
also der Index
von meinem Element in der Liste,
wo ich gerade bin,
dann kann man dieses Enumerate verwenden.
Das heißt, ich haue mal eine Liste
hier in dieses Enumerate Statement rein
und dann bekomme ich hier
immer ein Tuple raus.
Das heißt, hier habe ich den Index
und hier die Lecture.
Die Lecture, praktisch sind diese Werte
und der Index
stellt mir ein Enumerate zur Verfügung
und der wird dann von Enumerate
ausgeführt.
Das kann man sich dann so vorstellen.
Fortest
in Enumerate
ist man auch den Index.
Dann haben wir da
eins
Doppelpunkt
und dann kann ich da einfach sagen
Index
und Test.
Ups, was habe ich gemacht?
Ich habe das Enumerate vergessen.
Das ist vielleicht auch interessant hier,
also ich habe hier
zwei Variablen angegeben
aber davor hatte ich praktisch nur
zwei Werte funktioniert
und dann sagt er mir da einen
Value Error,
dass er praktisch zu viele
Values hat, die er da
immer aus einem Element
rausholen kann.
Wenn ich hier zum Beispiel
Tuple verwenden hätte,
dann hätte das funktioniert,
weil das hier immer zwei Werte sind.
Da könnt ihr dann selber
auch bis sie testen.
Das heißt, wir haben dann hier einfach
immer unseren Index ausgeprintet,
der eben auch wieder bei 0 startet,
0, 1, 2
und hier
dann dann eben einfach das Element,
das eben in diese Testvariable
geschrieben wird.
Gibt es da so Fragen?
Ja, Komma isch
zum ZIP.
Das ist dann eben
genau das, was ich eben gesagt habe
mit dem Duple.
Ihr habt da praktisch Lectures
und Teachers.
Wir sind ganz wichtig,
diese Listen sind beide gleich lang.
Das ist sehr wichtig, weil sonst wird
euch ZIP ein Fehler werfen,
wenn die Listen nicht gleich lang sind.
Und was ZIP macht,
es nimmt immer die ersten,
es nimmt immer an der selben Index
der beiden Listen hier
das gleiche Element her,
also hier Maths und Brown an der Stelle 0
und kombiniert die
zu einem Duple.
Praktisch haben wir dann einen Duple stehen,
der schaut dann eben so aus.
Ja.
Ich glaube, ich weiß gar nicht, ob ich das so machen kann.
Genau.
Das schaut dann eigentlich intern so aus,
dass ihr dann immer praktisch hier,
ihr seht immer 1
und 4 als Duple,
Speicherts 2 und 5 als Duple und 3 und 6.
Das kann man dann natürlich so machen.
Element 1,
Element 2 in
dann nehmen wir uns nochmal
das ZIP her, dann müsst ihr nicht unbedingt
das Ganze nochmal in eine Liste konvertieren.
Das Problem nämlich
ist, wenn ich
nur das ZIP ausgebe,
schaut das sehr unleserlich aus.
Da sind wir beim Problem wieder vor.
Und da machen wir dann das ZIP rein,
dann wieder den Doppelpunkt.
E1, E2
und dann könnt ihr das so ausbinden.
Gibt es da zu fragen?
Okay.
Dann gibt es noch so ein paar spezielle Keywords,
die ihr in Schleifen
verwenden könnt.
Das Pass.
Pass könnt ihr sogar überall im Programm verwenden.
Und das ist einfach nur ein Lehrerkommand.
Das ist zum Beispiel ganz praktisch,
wenn ihr beim Coden seid
und ihr wisst, okay,
ich will dann IF machen,
aber ich bin mir noch nicht ganz sicher,
was ich reinschreiben will.
Schreibe einfach ein Pass rein
und dann meckert's Beifen nicht,
weil wenn ich das nicht mache,
dann sagt er mir, oh, da fehlt was.
Aber da auch, dass ich eben
ein leeres Statement verwendet habe,
da passiert nix.
Aber ich habe eben schon dieses IF definiert,
weil ich später schon weiß, okay,
da kommt dann diese Erzweigung
im Programm rein, also
schreibe ich mal das rein
und dann später programmiere ich
den Rest des Codes aus,
da habe ich mal ein Pass rein.
Das Break und das Continue
ist nur ein Schleifen vor.
Das Break, das bricht die Schleife ab.
Zum Beispiel, ihr habt ein IF Statement erreicht,
also wo ihr sagt, okay,
ich bin jetzt ganz zufrieden
mit dem, was ich da gemacht habe.
Ich brauche den Rest der Schleife nicht mehr.
Break, also
abbrechen,
gehe ich aus der Schleife raus.
Continue ist so,
stellt ihr vor, seit ihr gerade
in der Schleife drin,
da wird gerade was berechnet.
Und da kommt jetzt auf ein Zwischenergebnis,
mit dem ihr auch wieder zufrieden seid.
Aber ihr möcht noch die
alle anderen Ergebnisse ausrechnen
in dieser Liste, die ihr damit
in der Schleife durchgeht.
Dann mache ich einfach Continue.
Das heißt,
der restliche Code
in der Schleife wird nicht mehr ausgeführt
und ich springe zum nächsten Element.
Also damit, das ist einfach wie ein
Element
und das Break ist wie
ich breche die Schleife komplett ab.
Die zwei kann man nicht in der IF Anweisung
verwenden, weil
das macht eigentlich wenig Sinn.
Genau.
Ja.
Das wäre es eigentlich eh schon
von diesem Teil der Vorlesung.